Ridley Scott is no stranger to special
effects but creating the red planet on
screen for the Martian may have been his
biggest challenge as a director while
some practical effects were used a huge
amount of digital work was required to
give the Martian Scott's desired look
VFX supervisor Anders lenglands told
Gizmodo Ridley Scott is famous for doing
his little sketches which are sort of
really cool Ridley grams we'd ask what
do you want the background mountains to
look like in this shot and he'd sketch
out a little diagram of what they wanted
so you just literally matched that and
he'd be happy a lot of time was spent
finding the right cue for the skies and
arid Landscapes of Mars though in the
end it was a simple thing that caused
the VFX team the most problems the
helmet visors but of course gloss visas
would reflect the crew and the lights
and the Sound Stage so all the helmet
visors you see in the film are actually
added in digitally